[Music]
the way in which the antithesis is
constituted in this ethical realm is
such that self-consciousness has not yet
received its due as a particular
individuality they already have the
value on the one hand merely of the
universal will and on the other of
consanguinity this particular individual
counts only as a shadowy unreality and
yet no deed has been committed but the
deed is the actual self it disturbs the
peaceful organization and movement of
the ethical world what there appears is
order and harmony of its two essences
each of which authenticates
and completes the other becomes through
the deed a transition of opposites in
which each proves itself to be the non
reality rather than the authentication
of itself and the other it becomes the
negative movement or the eternal
necessity of a dreadful fate which
engulfs in the abyss of its single
nature divine and human law alike as
well as the two self consciousnesses in
which these powers have their existence
and for us passes over into the absolute
being for self of the purely individual
self-consciousness
paragraph 464 now begin the next
subsection of the first portion of the
Spirit massive section of the work and
we're continuing on with this discussion
of the ethical order and the two sides
the human law and the divine law in this
shorter section we're now going to see
them actually coming to a head and Hegel
very early on in this is going to now
reintroduce self consciousness in a very
explicit and you might even say
disruptive way and that happened in this
very first paragraph so he tells us that
the ethical realm as we know is divided
into two sides right we have human law
on one side and here he's talking about
the universal will allgemeine avail
right and on the other side we have the
divine law the realm of the family and
here he's talking about consanguinity
that is people sharing the same blood
and we've gone through a lot of
interesting discussion about the nature
of family relations and you know the
hiddenness of the family as opposed to
the manifest necessity that the
relationship between the family and the
divine we've talked about the nature of
government over here on the human law
side all of these things are coming to a
head and Hegel tells us that what we
have here is in antithesis within the
ethical realm but it's an antithesis
that is not you know when we see this
term antithesis we usually think about
something where things are jarring with
each other and the way that he talks
about here is no not until we introduce
action or as it's being translated here
the deed right and the deed is going to
be associated with an individual who
does the deed think back all the way to
when we were talking about the attempt
to try to understand individuality
way back in the reason section in terms
of human action right there is a you
might say slipperiness to human action
particularly the more individual it got
we were always trying to bring it under
laws right we're always trying to make
sense of it in terms of explanatory or
normative principles and it seemed like
human beings are that kind of creature
where you pin them down here and they
wiggle away over here as the individual
now as the aggregate or in terms of the
universal we can perhaps pin them down
in this way much more easily but the
problem with that is the universal will
doesn't really act without acting
through individuals nor does
consanguinity the law the family the law
of the divine act without being involved
with individuals either so he tells us
the way in which the antithesis is
constituted in this ethical realm as its
antithesis that we've set up here is
such that self-consciousness has not yet
received its due as a particular
individuality does that mean that we
don't have self-consciousness no as a
matter of fact self-consciousness is
existing but in a general or universal
way over here on the side of the human
law perhaps with the government right
and existing in a kind of inchoate way
you might say self-consciousness that is
not fully conscious of itself as
self-consciousness on the side of the
family when we get to individuality
particular Angela into individuality
that's when the rubber you know that we
talk about proverbially hitting the road
really does get it's gripping point and
so we move from this antithesis into a
different entities that of the deed so
he said before that the particular
individuality individual counts only as
a shadowy unreality so he says as yet no
deed has been committed we were sort of
setting things up but the D
is the actual self action it's one thing
to talk about safe social dynamics or
the arrangement of a society and its
culture in terms of these two sides but
it's only when somebody does something
somebody stakes out a position
somebody acts that all of this really
means something and has any true reality
so he goes on and he says what happens
when you win somebody act it disturbs
the peaceful organization and movement
of the ethical world so what we had
going on here was a sort of you know
equilibrium or a a continual process now
we're introducing genuine human
spontaneity into this process and it
shakes it to two pieces ultimately so
what happens he says what there appears
is ordering as order and harmony of its
two essences right the the universal
will and consanguinity the human law and
the divine law understood in general as
forms of self-consciousness but not yet
individual self-consciousness what there
appears is harmony each of which
authenticates and completes the other
each of which is in some way making the
other valid you could say or adding the
side that that's needed right until we
have actual human beings and they're
determinant actions being introduced
everything is more or less running
smoothly it's when we introduce real
human beings with particular motives
although we're going to see a little bit
later on that these motives have to
still be moving within the realm of the
ethical that cannot be sort of V Neil
motives right or totally self-centered
motives or those of corruption right
trying to make a buck or you know get
something out of it so long as these
individuals
view themselves as trying to enact what
it is that the family and the divine on
the one hand or the human law and the
government require we're going to have a
massive disruption and the disruption
that goes all the way to the core we
might think here for example when
something that Hegel was talking about
much earlier in terms of self
consciousness going all the way back to
the beginning of the self consciousness
section and the master-slave dialectic
when Hegel talked about self
consciousness being shaken to it's very
core and saying that dialectical
progression was not really going to
happen unless this being shaken to it's
very core occurred on the part altom
Utley of the slave right where the
progress would then could take place
something similar is happening here in
the ethical domain with these two
principles these two laws so he goes on
and he says what happens through the
deed is there's a transition of opposite
and now I wanted to put this on the
board in part because there's a little
bit of a I don't know if it's a
deliberate play on words or if Hegel is
just using similar vocabulary we started
out with a Gagan Zod a antithesis or if
you like contradiction right and then
soon after that we're now finding that
when we make the transition through the
deed to two particular individuals who
are representing or embodying the
universal will and the principle of the
family now we have an Kagan Gazette stir
we have things that are you notice the
Gagan Gagan Gazette's they're here
that's like Dagon's I write very similar
not exactly the same but but lexically
closely related right this is actually
from from a longer composite you've got
the end there they're set apart and yet
in collision with each other you might
say
and that is going to be really critical
what we have here now with these
opposites is they are no longer
complementary to each other in fact
something else is occurring Hegel tells
us that rather than being the
authentication or the validation of
itself and the other each proves itself
to be the non reality each proves itself
to be lacking in reality to be
incomplete so interestingly the deed
which was required to actually make
things actual complete vir clicks is
making them in some respect less so this
is actually an advance however Hegel
goes on and says it becomes the negative
movement or the eternal necessity of a
dreadful fate which engulfs in the abyss
of a single nature divine in human law
alike as well as the two self
consciousnesses in which these powers
have their existence so what is
happening on both sides is the and this
is what's going to be happening in the
rest of this this section is that each
of these is generating not only its own
unreality but also the non reality of
its opposite and of this whole schema to
begin with you you might say if we want
to think in terms of how Hegel has
figured this before what they are doing
is introducing death as the absolute
master in here at this point as pure
negativity and Hegel will end this
paragraph by talking about the absolute
being for self of individual
consciousness right our individual self
consciousness that is what everything is
passing over into and now we have to see
well what does that individual
self-consciousness look like in these
cases
the ground from which this movement
starts in at which it takes place is the
ethical realm what is active in this
movement however it is self
consciousness quiet achill consciousness
it is the simple pure direction of
activity towards the essentiality of
ethical life that is duty in if there is
no Caprice and equally no struggle no
indecision so if the making and testing
of law has been given up on the contrary
the essence of ethical life is for this
consciousness immediate unwavering
without contradiction consequently we
are not faced of the sorry spectacle of
a collision between passion and duty nor
with the comic spectacle of a collision
between duty and duty a collision which
is regards its content is the same as
that between passion and duty for
passion is equally capable of being seen
as a duty because when consciousness
separates itself from its immediate
substantial essence and withdraws into
itself it becomes a merely formal
universal into which one content as well
as another fits equally well as we found
before but the collision of duties is
comic because it expresses a
contradiction that is the contradiction
of an absolute that as opposed to itself
and absolute and then the nothingness of
this so-called absolute or duty the
ethical consciousness however knows what
it has to do and has already decided
whether to belong to the divine or these
human law this immediate firmness of
decision is something implicit and
therefore has at the same time the
significance of a natural being as we
have seen nature not the accident of
circumstances or choice assigns one sex
to one law the other to the other law or
conversely the to ethical powers
themselves give themselves an individual
existence and actualize themselves in
the two sexes
in paragraph 485 Hegel is telling us a
bit more about the self-consciousness
that is engaged in what he's calling the
ethical realm so we're talking about
ethical self-consciousness and remember
now at this point that we are talking
about an individual self-consciousness
that is taking a particular stand we've
moved away from what we could call the
general or universal self-consciousness
that was associated with one or two of
the laws it's still going to be
associated with one or two of them as we
see there's a choice that has to be made
or at least at the very least something
like a commitment let's call it but now
we're talking about a consciousness that
is you know individual and oriented
entirely like he puts it here it's
involved in a simplicity that is an
activity directed or oriented towards
duty towards flicked in Hegel's German
so he tells us what is active in this
movement is self-consciousness in order
for the ethical realm to be able to to
do what it does in a way that it
produces any sort of development it has
to be through individual
self-consciousness
so he says qua ethical consciousness it
is the simple pure direction of activity
toward the essentiality of ethical life
the essentiality of ethical life here is
what Hegel is calling duty and that's
typically how ethical life is framed we
don't have it simply in terms of these
abstract principles it's you should do
this and we saw it earlier in the entire
section on you know for the end of the
reason portion of the text reason giving
itself laws and then reason testing laws
we saw what some of those duties in fact
could be like you should you know love
your neighbor or you
should respect property or we can go
through these things and these are set
out as as sort of norms and at the same
time they're incumbent upon a person so
they can be very specific as well you
know your parent is old and sick you
must do something in relation to your
parent we could talk about funerary
rites you know how long do you have to
remain in mourning and wearing a certain
color and not partaking in certain
pleasures these are all what Hegel is
calling duties here so he says that
quiet ethical consciousness it's
directed towards duty and he says in it
there is no Caprice equally no struggle
no indecision why because the making and
testing of laws has been given up this
is the transition at the end of the
reason section into the spirit section
we had this movement from you know a
rational self-consciousness that was
giving itself ethical laws as the
Jacques Alps as the project and
eventually it reached a point where it
transitioned over into finding the the
ethical substance given to it and now it
commits to that so there's no Caprice
there's no Wilk er right there's no
arbitrariness to this there is no
struggle no cop as Hegel says and
there's no indecision or we might even
translate it indecisiveness one and
shied in Heights right a lack of heav'n
shite in height a lack of imposing a
shied in a splitting a I'm taking this
and rejecting this no wavering no
oscillating between that no
second-guessing we might say so what do
we find in this he says on the contrary
the essence of ethical life is for this
consciousness immediate unwavering
without contradiction without Vitas
Brooke so he goes on he says we're not
faced with a collision between duty and
duty or duty
and passion now why why not Hegel is
going to say it quite a few things about
this so we're not faced with a collision
between duty and duty because we're
going to follow a duty and collisions
between the two of them are not going to
arise there will be duties done on the
two opposite side that will themselves
find themselves in collision but those
are in different self consciousnesses
they're not in the same
self-consciousness the one
self-consciousness over here knows what
its duty is and the other Duty doesn't
matter for it as we're going to see it
ultimately doesn't have reality in this
it's discussed in the later paragraphs
Hegel tells us it's not going to be the
collision of duty and passion here he
tells us something quite interesting he
says a collision between duty and Duty
would be the same as regards its content
as that between passion and Duty light
in shopton and duty right
why because passion is equally capable
of being seen as a duty why is passion
equally able as being seen as a duty
well we saw this play out in previous
shapes of consciousness didn't we like
the you know pleasure and necessity or
the law the heart and frenzy of
self-conceit all of these sorts of
things that consciousness could identify
itself with and say ah this is what it
is what I desire this is what is going
to drive me this is where I'll find
fulfilment that can be transformed into
something like a duty to oneself I
should I should enjoy every pleasure
available to me I should become a
gourmet right those people take those
seriously enough and they turn them into
a duty and now Hegel says something
really interesting here he says when
consciousness separates itself from its
immediate substantial essence which is
getting from the ethical sphere and
withdraws into itself it becomes the
merely formal universal into it one
content as well as another fifth equally
well so we can place whatever we want
into it we can cram whatever happens to
fit under this rubric of passion and
turn it into a duty the other thing that
he says it's particularly striking about
this is that this collision would be
comic now usually when we talk about to
ethical you know imperatives or duties
or values running into each other and
not being compatible we don't usually
talk about that as comic we usually talk
about that in terms of tragedy so why is
Hagel talking about comedy here that's a
really important question he says the
collision of duties in comic because it
expresses a contradiction
what kind of contradiction the
contradiction of an absolute that is
opposed to itself now why would that be
funny
rather than tragic well I mean think
about it an absolute shouldn't be
opposed to really anything nothing
should be able to stand up against it
should encompass everything but we find
that it's opposed to it's very self of
course this is inherent in the nature of
dialectics isn't it but for those who
are looking at things in this sense if
some sort of you know division arises in
the middle of the ethical absolute well
that is in certain respects of
catastrophe from people looking at it
from the outside they're like oh my God
look at this they can't get it together
there's something comic something funny
about it
so he says the nothingness of this
so-called absolute or duty is indeed
comic then he says the ethical
consciousness doesn't worry about that
it knows what it has to do and he says
it's already decided for one side or the
other it has decided either for human
law or for divine law it takes its cues
from that source that is what's
providing the simplicity here
and it more or less ignores the other
law on this is why you know we saw just
with Pat the paragraph earlier Hegel was
saying when this this sort of thing is
taking place through individuality what
we're sort of validating or
authenticating each other these two
sides now we're are suddenly turned into
these opposites to each other that
nullify each other and that is what's
going to take place as he goes on now he
also tells us that this firmness of
decision he says has at the same time
the significance of a natural being
nature not the accident of circumstances
or choice assigns one sex to one law you
know the male is assigned to human law
female is assigned to divine law and he
says conversely the to ethical powers
give themself an individual existence
and actualize themselves in the two
sexes so Hegel seems to be saying that
there's a kind of gender determinism
happening here within the scope of the
the ethical substance and the splitting
into the two laws you know one of the
questions that we could ask is does it
have to go that way was was Hegel you
know so captivated by the Antigone story
or narrative that that he needed to
weave it in this way or is there some
you know is this tied just with older
cultures or is there something else
going on here and I want to leave that
an open question because it's not able
to be really resolved at this point we
know that Hegel does want to say the two
saxes or two genders are being portioned
out by nature but we saw that there's
already more to the story than just some
sort of sexual difference going on
you